what's going on guys this is rob and we
are going to explain the ending of moon
knight episode 4 because i feel like
this really really
is confusing to a lot of people but the
way that is handled is brilliant they're
kind of doing it the opposite of how it
was how would normally be handled but
it's still cool nonetheless so uh
obviously there's gonna be spoilers here
but near the end of the episode this is
more like an ending sequence explained
but near the end of the episode uh mark
specter or basically the body of mark
and or steve grant is shot by arthur
harrow and then at that point he kind of
dies but not really it looks like he
goes more to what's basically a way
station or like a purgatory before he
actually goes on to the afterlife again
we're not really given any definitive
answers here but there is some
similarity in terms of what's going on
because there's there's obviously
differences between this and like jeff
lemire's run but there's a lot of very
similar things uh in the story line what
is it welcome to new egypt i think is
what it was called um i know the second
one is called uh life birth and death i
think or maybe just birth and death but
the important thing here is this once
mark specter's shot he ends up in this
kind of purgatory place that was really
cool and the way this is handled albeit
a little
i wouldn't say sloppily um that you kind
of have this whole sequence with uh with
arthur harrow now right off the bat this
gave me legion vibes right it felt like
something from legion the difference
here is that legion had a far more
extensively crafted aspect of whether or
not
david holler was crazy or if he was
really in an asylum you didn't really
know exactly what was going on granted
they had more than like
15 minutes
to kind of craft this whole narrative so
i get what they were going for to a
degree because once he basically wakes
up in this asylum and then like he's
talking to himself believing he can talk
to steve but steve's not answering him
so it's basically just
mark in there by himself his girl's
there you end up seeing donna there
which fingers crossed she died she was a
prick uh you have all these different
people seemingly from like the life of
mark specter right the people that we've
seen so far some of whom we presumably
haven't seen but have been a part of his
life that they're all basically there
and that ultimately he ends up waking up
again in the office of arthur harrow
having previously been sedated and
basically arthur harrow doesn't
necessarily come out right and say it
but basically he hinted this idea that
like mark spector struggles with
schizophrenia now one of the things to
know is this is somewhat old hat jeff
lemire did revisit this in his comic
book run to a degree but back in the
early days of mark spector's comic book
appearances he was basically a
schizophrenic guy he couldn't
differentiate between reality and
fantasy ultimately that schizophrenia
went away and he ended up just having
disassociative identity disorder or
multiple personality disorder you may
know it as that name as well but
basically having multiple personalities
inside of his own mind and so the way
this worked what was really cool about
this what i really really loved is they
were kind of toying with this idea that
maybe mark spector really is crazy he's
just a guy in an asylum now again
because of the fact there wasn't a whole
lot of time devoted to this it felt a
little bit like an afterthought if
that's what they were going for but if
you were looking at it and really kind
of taking it for what it was it was like
okay
something bigger is going on here this
isn't simply just like you know marvel
studios being like actually mark
spector's crazy you know it wasn't
really them doing that thank god
but all the little symbology right so
like the staff of arthur harrow was
basically there but it was just a
regular cane um of course he was wearing
those sandals that he normally puts
glass in which isn't necessarily the
case while he does look different uh he
doesn't look like a like a hippie just
tripping on lsd uh of course he still
has the limp which is cool and then you
basically get the orderlies now as soon
as that happened i kind of had a feeling
that this was basically uh like jeff
lemire's you know whole uh mark specter
in an insane asylum run i kind of had a
feeling that was the case but as soon as
i saw i saw the orderlies i was like
okay i know what's going on here now um
so here's what's happening so far or at
least in this this tail end
so in jeff lemire's run this is why i
see they're doing it the opposite way in
jeff lemire's run this is actually how
it opened up that basically mark spectre
was in an insane asylum and the whole
idea was being teased here that in
reality mark specter was just crazy like
he was just a guy who was literally
insane and that was basically it there
wasn't really anything more to it than
that but you knew he had these kind of
multiple personalities that kind of
thing but as the story progressed and as
it got towards the end of the first arc
it was basically mark coming to this
realization that like the steve grant
and the jake lockley and the mark
specter personas that he's largely just
been ignoring them for too long and what
this did is it led to a fractured psyche
now the other part of this and the way
this story was initially pitched to us
by jeff lemire is this is actually what
kanchi would do because the whole insane
asylum thing that was all conscious
doing that was basically him
manipulating mark spector and this is
where the revelation came out that what
khanshi would do and presumably other
egyptian god avatars which may or may
not have been the case since konchu is
really the only one who's had an avatar
for any real measure of time that what
would happen here is they would select a
person to basically be their avatar on
earth and as time went on they would
manipulate them they would screw with
their heads and then ultimately they
would launch this kind of end game where
they would basically hollow out what was
left of them to where that person would
just be an empty shell with no real
meaningful consciousness and what that
would do is it would basically allow
consu or any other egyptian god to enter
that host body and then walk on earth
which presumably would mean that mark
specter in terms of personalities mark
specter steve grant jake lockley they
would be gone they would basically be
destroyed personalities but conscie
would still have all his power intact so
as far as we would see it as a comic
book reader it would basically be mark
specter with like god-like powers it
would be really really cool to see what
ended up happening shortly after that is
writer max bemis came out and basically
said well the whole intention of the
entire jeff lemire run was to basically
cure mark of his mental illness
basically curing him of his
disassociative identity disorder and the
idea was that over the course of that
story that mark spector basically came
to terms with his other personalities
instead of ignoring jake lockley and
steve grant he actually embraced them
and what it did is it led to a more
cohesive version of mark spector himself
and then following that they quote
unquote symbolically killed konchu which
basically unified him and essentially
fixed him of his disassociative identity
disorder and then following that he just
went forward as mark specter slash moon
knight and did his thing in the comics
it was really cool now what you're
seeing here because what also happened
in there is you ended up finding out
that like ammit basically had a role in
that right she was part of the whole
illusion all that kind of stuff i would
say that what they're doing here is
they're borrowing from jeff lemire's run
but they're not doing it in its entirety
that the whole idea is that with mark
spector basically being shot by arthur
harrow and then waking up in this kind
of purgatory that ammit has no intention
of seizing control of arthur harrow of
basically having him become her avatar
instead she's likely seeking out mark
spector and this whole sequence that you
see going on here is basically amit
messing with mark spector and tending to
basically quote unquote hollow him out
destroy his personalities and then take
his body for herself and then be reborn
in human form on earth and then have all
these insane powers so she can conquer
all of existence so instead of being
like the other egyptian gods that have
avatars well they basically you know use
them as more of like communication
vessels as opposed to using them in the
same way that like conscious uses mark
specter is like an anti-hero slash
vigilante slash moon knight type guy
then instead she'll quite literally
operate here whether that means the
other egyptian gods will step in i'm not
entirely sure uh we don't necessarily
know here but i would surmise that's
most likely what's going on whether or
not that's the case only time will tell
but one big distinction to know here is
one this is the first time that mark
spector and steve grant are meeting
face to face as it were right where
they're actually two different
personalities talking to each other
that's how you know it's in the
mindscape because they're physically
able to embrace each other it's exactly
what happened in uh in jeff lemire's run
but following that there were two other
cool things that happened here the first
one is we got a kind of depiction or at
least a little bit of a tease of the
jake lockley persona now again in marvel
comics jake lockley is a cab driver who
just who fights more like a brawler than
anything else but he's not nearly as
trained and he's not like he's not like
a like a mercenary type guy like mark
specter is in the tv show it looks
totally different um it looks like to
some degree jake lockley is like a
psychopathic killer i don't really know
or he's just he's just nuts who knows
whatever it is he seems incredibly
capable and pretty brutal right because
we know in the last episode with those
three guys those those three henchmen um
that were trying to attack him that like
mark spector passed out or basically the
personalities switched and then when he
took back control again he thought it
was steve grant who had killed those
guys and he's like it wasn't me so
obviously there was a third person there
but that's never been the kind of person
jake lockley is so assuming it is jake
lockley they're changing him for the
show which i'm excited about because i
always thought jake lockley was for the
most part useless so i'm really excited
to see
what they do with this character i mean
right now all we know is he's locked
away in a sarcophagus i don't think we
heard his voice we just saw or just just
like saw him like pounding on the inside
of the sarcophagus and then they ignored
him and that was basically it the real
question is why they ignore him right
that's that's the question like does
mark specter know about jake lockley at
least on some level does steve grant
know about him on on like some level
like not in the sense that they're aware
of his personality but in the sense that
like when they see that potential
personality there they just feel a kind
of threat of imminent danger so they're
just like stay away
on a subconscious level like you know
you know how it is like when you get
that that hair that that comes up on
your on your arms or something like that
you're like okay something really bad's
about to happen that kind of feeling
right almost like a sort of spider sense
to a degree but the last thing we get is
to warrant i think it's how you
pronounce it i've always been really
really fuzzy about that basically the
hippo goddess she does not appear in the
comics first things first she is not in
marvel comics as far as i'm aware at all
and i have i'm
fairly familiar with the different
egyptian gods and goddesses that exist
out there so um i am not aware of her
appearing there it looks like they
actually grabbed her from the real world
egyptian mythos and brought her into the
tv show technically she represents like
life death rebirth that kind of a thing
you know regeneration so on and so forth
so in the show she's likely a stand-in
for the metaphysical point that jeff
lemire was making which is moon knight
being reborn that's basically what it is
if anything she'll probably be the means
by which mark specter reconciles his
other personalities particularly with
jake lockley and like that's it right it
may be one of these things where quite
literally they have a powwow it's like
the three of them sitting in a circle
and they're all talking to each other
and like figuring out what's going on
i have no real idea i am excited to find
out i was a little on the fence about
moon night right i was like god it's a
slow burn you know what now it's really
got my attention it kind of sucks that
we only got two episodes left
but it's really got my attention and i
absolutely love it i think it's only six
episodes so i'm really really digging it
so far um you know it took a little
while to get to this point i feel like
we could have gotten to this point a
little bit faster but i also understood
why they paced it the way that they did
um having said that that's basically the
ending the whole sequence explained in
effect what's happening here is mark
spector is not really dead maybe he is
maybe he isn't he looks like he's more
in like a mental purgatory uh kind of
stuck in his own mind is basically what
it is like most likely he's still just
laying there in the water and he's not
dead yet arthur herrera will likely end
up just walking away right he'll take
his henchman and just leave and he'll
assume that mark specter's dead and then
like you know his girl will like run up
and save him or something like that and
so all this entire sequence will have
taken place in the span of maybe like 30
seconds to a minute or something like
that or some other some some other third
aspect will come in but basically he'll
end up coming to you and he'll still be
alive but his mind will be fixed is
basically what it is so uh with that
being said guys thanks for watching uh
let me know what you guys think about
episode four right let me know what you
guys think about this episode and i will
catch you all later
peace